oui vauvert star internationale rudy ça
vous énerve quand on dit que vous êtes
le sportif le mieux payé au monde ce que
ses fans français c'est le c'est vrai ça
ne marche pas ça vous énerve toi je peux
donner votre salaire ou pas sûr alors
est alors là je peux te dire frères ça
va nous calmer la lah castaldi et on
l'entend plus qu'à la phase aller c'est
la nouvelle du basket
non c'est pas mal je le ferais quoi que
c'est à lui dire je ne dis pas mal à
vendre
merci 23 25 millions d'heureux dollars
par an son douar dollars en dollars
donc on a la vue bah ouais mais c'est
comme ça voilà vous êtes un rêve d'être
le plus gros efforts mais français je
vous dis